[Music]
angela joins us in lexington kentucky
angela how can we help
hi um thank you guys for taking my call
and actually hoping that ken you would
be on the show today because my question
is
specifically for you okay
and i work with some
young adults and kids i'm a little bit
older than them so i call them all kids
um
and i am trying to
mentor them kind of sort of um
to stay away from debt and things
because i don't
want them to have the same regrets that
i have you know graduate graduating
college and going into you know their
lives as adults
um
and so i
here on the show sometimes you telling
people kind of
uh what kind of questions to ask
themselves as far as careers and and um
like their purpose in life and things
like that and so i'm setting up a uh
library budget uh day kind of with some
of them and so i wanted to ask those
questions um so that i can kind of give
them a better idea of what they want
their futures to look like because some
have an idea some don't
um and some are just choosing college
just to choose college and i'm like no
don't do that yeah well so let me give
you a very basic set of questions that
really uh it's the whole methodology
that i teach and this is how someone
gets clear and this is how we take this
big giant idea of purpose that seems so
intimidating and so mythical and so hard
to figure out and we simplify it so here
are the questions what do they do best
what do they do best that's talent every
person on the planet was born with
talent they'll acknowledge that so we
want to just begin to have some fun
conversations with them let's not make
this big career oriented conversation
let's take the pressure off of young
adults because they don't have a ton of
life experience so we just start talking
about what do you do best hard skills
soft skills right so for one person they
might be really gifted
artistically right
another person might be very good
mechanically what do they do best that's
a hard skill then the soft skills
otherwise known as people skills so
you've got hard skills and people skills
what do they do best uh then the second
question is
what work do you love to do now
again the younger the person
the uh
the more exploration they're going to
have to do on this question because they
don't have 10 years of work
maybe they don't even have a degree yet
as you've talked about they don't have a
major so they're still trying to figure
it out but what work do they love to do
and i would break it down to task and
function you know you think about doing
work one day work that you think might
be enjoyable or even in high school uh
if you begin to wonder about it or you
saw somebody else do something you saw
them at career day even as an 8th grader
you went that's interesting we want to
begin to have the conversation and say
what kind of work do you think you would
enjoy doing just the task
or the role itself and then finally
what results do you want to put out in
this world and all work create results
so this is fun for somebody young
because now we get away from career
titles we get away from paths we just go
what contribution would you like to make
to the world through your work and
there's there's a three-part question
within this one okay i know i'm hitting
you with a lot of questions but this is
the key
these questions allow people to make
everything personal and so they dig
who are the people they most want to
help and when they begin to think of the
people they most want to help they can
also identify this what's the problem
they have or the desire they have
doesn't always have to be a problem
could be a desire
you know a 19 year old could say you
know i want to help people that have a
desire to look beautiful
and so they could turn into a whole
career esthetician cutting hair you know
but whatever makeup artist whatever
clothing designer so personal trainer
personal trainer so we're looking at who
are the people i most want to help the
problem or desire those people have and
then what's the solution to that problem
or desire that i most get fired up about
now when we start talking about that
third little part the solution to the
problem with the desire
then the ideas about occupation begin to
kind of surface and more importantly
what i'm giving you here is a
conversation starter
and then a conversation returner have
these conversations over and over have
them put out real answers have them then
talk to men and women that are that are
doing the work that they're kind of
throwing out there as maybes and i think
the younger that you can get them
thinking about this and exploring and
discovering and talking to others that's
going to be really really good and i
would point you to our get clear career
assessment we've got a 20 minute
assessment online
that if you're 19 18 19 you're still
going to get some good from it even if
you don't have a lot of work experience
and you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com and that's a
wonderful little tool that'll give them
a purpose statement a working purpose
statement that's not in stone but they
can begin to have a more detailed
conversation that's great yeah so i
appreciate the call and john i you know
you you
you were in the education industry you
know part of the thing that i think
i'm trying to fight
through our traditional education model
and this comes from culture and parents
and parents are kind of getting it from
culture is that we're sending kids off
to colleges that have massive amounts of
pressure to pick the right major
and and just figure it all out and get
the absolute best job right job out of
college i get that there's nothing wrong
with that but to me where we're
eliminating
the discovery that i think needs to
happen from 18 to 21 and just diving
deep on that simple of a conversation
you know i remember when my son was in
first grade
they were talking about what college
you're going to go to yeah it's nuts to
me i was thinking he's learning numbers
dude right what
right i was 35 i don't know what i want
to do with my life back you know what i
mean so yeah the pressure we put on
people from ages six to yeah
it's just bananas so that little simple
process is just about by the way what
you just said about i want to help
people look their best you can become a
chemist you can create the weight room
equipment you can run a gym you can
there's a thousand ways to solve that
problem that's exactly right